yeah hello welcome to our monday evening
broadcast one hour of blitz really
looking forward to the session haven't
played a single blitz game today so I
hope this will be fun okay hello to all
of you also in the chat on YouTube I'm
going to kick off with a hope some
five-minute games and see what happens
yeah also an update on my youtube
channel i have not uploaded blitz games
last two days or three days even i
simply simply couldn't do it yeah i was
away from home and didn't manage to
upload them beforehand it was not
possible so i hope i'm back tomorrow
with my regular program let's say on my
channel ok playing drama dog I am drama
da said Jasper hall I kind of yes just
the whole yeah also I have to do without
any non-alcoholic beer to tonight I did
not manage to buy new one each for
what's the beep what is he doing here
what is H for
Oh head so funny and something there's
some questions are really funny there's
a question here by aboard sir if I had
to rob a bank or the chest crew who
would you choose a guy to distract the
crowd one guy to block the door and one
guy to drive the car oh wow that stuff
driving the car is probably difficult I
think probably for the car I go with the
Luke when really he's known to drive
pretty fast and well you know that's
probably a good thing for that job maybe
I could drive the car I'm not a good
driver but I can drive reasonably fast
if I need to so I'm one guy to distract
the crowd yeah probably let's let's yes
well I could probably talk talk people
yeah and yeah that's a good idea been
fine go to block the door that's
probably not a bad idea he certainly has
some some kind of yeah good physical
presence to make this possible to block
it yeah yeah not many people not there
are top chopped GMS without driving
lights as there are there are many I
knew that that Luke when will he has
warned he drives a BMW as I could
witness when he drove to two Dean's
Larkin to to to play against me he
arrived in this 3 series BMW okay so
what is this I wanted to get the night
over to c4 okay
I think this father for a more stable
center yeah here drama da mr. Hall he's
a very resourceful tactical player then
he arranged to distract the crowd this
is also a good bad he's a really a
really good trash talker John choose
viddler to drive the car does justice
whitley have a license it's possible he
strikes it strikes me off a more of a
practical person and compared to many
other top GM's but you never know yeah
we do he won't exchange greens air but I
still wanted to try ok so I think the
king is reasonably safe here no I don't
plan to come to munching lot but for the
Kasparov simultaneous display I am I
don't quite understand why they um well
they spent really an enormous amount of
money on that and cuz Provost I mean
still yeah it is a very interesting
character but I don't really see why
should you should spend so much money on
this kind of event with that kind of
money you could probably em support
junior players to to become very strong
players
and yeah I'd rather invest money on that
then get Kasparov yeah top players don't
even have don't have driver's license
that often it's kind of kind of strange
I think quite often they travel a lot
and they maybe don't need to drive much
at home
so that's some firepower already Bishop
to c4 is Queen 33 sacrificing doesn't
win yet but maybe I can bring more over
here yeah magnus carlsen actually owns a
tesla model s but doesn't have a license
to drive it which I find very quite
quite funny so we're here such she can
take you five but I'll take be three
there's a question what's my favorite
chess game I don't have a super clear
favorite and maybe a rod laver
Rubinstein the famous sacrifices that
Rubinstein played in that game are just
fantastic of course there are many other
great games how can I draw a guy don't
have a driving license yeah I think it's
true what meat grinders saying they
quite often have people who take care of
that so um it's a it's it's not strictly
necessary for them to to need to drive
ok I try to bust this open here with you
for you can check but after King c6 I
don't see a clear continuation 95 maybe
it's still kind of dangerous I probably
could have taken on b3 already I'm not
totally sure here c4 looks good down
okay yeah crashing through there is a
discussion about the modern standards
variation in the Rue La Paz I don't
really know I mean why why why do you
think someone says it's passive it's not
a passive line at all Jack I don't
really don't really regard it as passive
there are many lines with g6 for example
that I rather rather shop at the end
yeah yeah I'm breaking through white
resigns yep tough tough tough tough yeah
I think here the attack on the queenside
just was stronger he took some liberties
there with with taking on a six okay
it's rather it's tough it's unclear but
I think I'm okay him so trying for a new
game yeah i see that i saw the Blitz
challenge I don't know what it was
called like ultimate village challenge
or so with the Nakamura Caruana Wesley
so and of course Kasparov and it was a
cool event really cool it man I hope
they do more of that I mean if you get
Casper off yet pay him lots of money let
him play chess and not discuss some some
some stuff that pretty much is not very
interesting to be honest I think what
he's doing there in Germany is not
playing here he's um he's pleased I'm
discussing some business things I'm not
quite sure what it is but it's not
solely chairs my children 9 is 9 g 7 and
9 mm no I understand that nobody wants
to play that it is not particularly
great it's just that I sometimes get to
get back to it in blitz like I don't
know it's against some players it is not
a bad choice against most players it is
a bad shots okay I have a request for a
new game but it's not much going on in
the five-minute pool at the moment I
don't know yeah it's dumb pleased to be
doing something I would need to look it
up but game okay playing vermeer oh no
someone said what do the Dutchman I can
play the Dutch yeah let's see okay this
line okay I go g6
hmm I think this is the line but having
kind of inventing things here over the
board I had a section at 9i with d5 mmm
there's a request for the Schleck terse
laughs I really don't know why people
would want me to play that that's a
question my den imbrue can one make a
living out of playing chess at a lower
level than GM I mean like I am or FM and
if yes what would be that level either
writing no you can't if you just want to
play the game and get money for it it's
impossible you can as an FM you can be
quite okay with teaching if you get to
teach at schools or things get them get
one-on-one lessons there are many many
ways of getting and getting getting by
then but it will be it's almost
impossible as a player have a
replacement Sigourney I'm thinking about
a couple of things but I don't really
get to get to work much on my own
openings at the moment I really dedicate
most of the time to what my students
play or now I have a job and two weeks
to help the German not the German genius
is wrong help the gern the juniors from
my area when they compete in the German
US Championship so i will work on on
those opening so with them but not on
that's a question what I think about the
modern defense that Castro love played
against Wesley so yeah well if you lose
a game like that one one game that cusp
of lost it looks like a pretty bad
choice but it's hindsight is
twenty-twenty em I think in general this
is rather playable for black so what's
happening here yeah I can take default
but it looks very scary but if I don't I
mean what was the point of it ok so here
I can give an intermediate check maybe
this is the point ok no Bishop t2
actually Queen takes Bishop c3 is
actually pretty awful so I'm going to
take with the Queen we should be five
there should be seven ok another
question do I think that all 22 plus
players in the five-minute poor a title
players assuming that they're not to
cheat us not all of them certainly most
of them but you have some there are
people who are really good at blitz that
are not titled so it's not one hundred
percent it's not it's not really not all
of them
so what am i doing
I don't like my position that plane
Knight f6 there is Bishop b5 well maybe
97 then it's actually not that bad I
don't like it I need to get Castle Tim
check Bishop g6 looked at bishop that
was a costly game that guy had a non
raging oh my goodness ah oh my god okay
okay that happens when you play the
Dutch and have no idea okay let's see
what I can do against tactical Zoltan
Madhvi ji ah that's cool now okay so we
get some kind of some BOGO Indian type
of position so um any questions would I
try a Smith Maura with white hmm yeah
maybe I can't play I can't play you for
and see what happens um okay so we get a
get a transposition to Zurich variation
um I there's a question what happens in
the first session with the new student
this is actually easy because I do the
same thing with all students in the
first sessions and look at one or more
of their own games this is the first
thing they should send me a couple of
their games as many as possible and i
will look through them and see um
whatever I feel is some um yeah useful
for them to study so it's a
it's a quite quite the same what I do
pretty much regardless of playing
strength okay I'm here tacticals allowed
'if 5 i'd see i have Queenie for here
I've Bishop d3 both them both are good I
think I go Queenie form he will go 95 I
guess 3g for I don't get with the bishop
on these three are just kind of a shame
but the e5 pawn is Sam is pretty
annoying um b6 yeah so I'll go Bishop
into my castle no I don't play d4 Knight
f6 g4 and it's not a good line and it's
not play background masters it's just
completely complete nonsense I would
definitely wear a mexican hat if someone
sends me 10 I come here by tacticals
it's a bit of a I don't know I can still
go here right I threaten Bishop h6
winning the exchange it's got the earth
porn but Bishop g5 is a is a serious
idea
okay so but take what does he doing
Queen takes or hmm I wonder if I should
take I probably yes son ultimately you
have to take almost so here this is a
checked but ok I'll just I'll just
cancel here hey maybe he's got a five
and twenty four was more precise that's
a shame that I'm letting him out of this
this was really a really bad position
for black or is it or is it still bad
hmm don't know it's then live stream
next week yes I think I think there will
be I don't think there will be one in
two weeks because then i will be at the
German youth championships or junior
championships and not being able to make
any produce any stream okay Bishop f5 we
are not happy with this absolutely not
before maybe hey he's got a form
hmm
efore in the 94 is immensely immensely
annoying p 395 is bad hmm not good not
good at all yeah absolutely absolutely
bad yes German you searched is in
villing on jung-in in the silent German
area yeah so um what about this right to
do for really not a good position bit of
a shame after the Miss played black
opening you should you should get a very
substantial advantage and I didn't
manage so what now look here maybe can
even play the 3m
maybe I can get the porn huh and would
be nice very very undeserved but maybe I
can get it check
yeah if I take it I don't select
continuation here this is the thing we
should be three looks shaky but at least
i don't see exactly what he's doing is
playing very quickly so
it's not so easy though I hope
top fan with this time already tough I
mean night a 2 or something an idea to
is probably correct
19 seconds check check check Karen I
don't know position might not maybe is
the lost but I'm not totally sure jack
okay he found a nice checkmate him mate
yeah I simply cannot I should simply
punish the opening this is this is just
a very bad position for black with this
pawn on e5 but I couldn't I couldn't
really punish it to the fullest probably
this is still benim trying to provoke
the weaknesses immediately maybe better
I looked at this when I wrote my book
and it's not a good variation from back
anyway so let's see what happens in the
next game playing Rama samiam you're
deformed so um so what do we see young
any question yeah the under-25 section
the German Junior Championships ism this
is an open section therefore not as
strong so um let's see any questions the
best way to handle the english defence
against 1c4 I think c4b 64 is pretty
good are there any interesting games for
blitz cute sing on the ISS see it's
something that I can try ok i will play
a couple of games
myself I haven't played any online bits
for a couple of days with probably
chosen of it but we'll see maybe I can
actually win some later so this line hmm
okay sometimes this is an interesting
move but I'm not sure about this here
record each was kind of wrong but I can
fix that and so then he says that he
tends to overlook moves by his opponents
in all the ball tournament games but not
so much tactical once but calm ones um
yeah so what kind of car move do you
overlook this is the important thing if
you overlook things that John I'm what's
happening here am i winning material
yeah I'm winning some material him and
if you are if you get what's this I can
take this I only get through 25 so I
have to take the rook and a little bit
too many questions yeah yeah about the
car moves um yeah so what kind of moves
to your overlooked if you overlook moves
that that improve the opponent's
position somewhere strategically it
makes sense to focus more on what the
other guys actually threatening ya think
about what is long-term strategic goals
are maybe this would be very very
helpful if um if you're unsure what is
what his goals are it's sometimes as
simple as trying to understand his his
last move the last move that the
opponent played I know that sounds very
basic but it's very often a good idea
just to ask yourself what the other guy
what did he just play and how did it
change the position quite often this is
a key idea and understanding what's
going on ok so I try to get stuff traded
but it is it is dangerous it just it is
just dangerous what can you do
so one of those cases where the other
guy blundered but it still has a
position okay this I did not think about
that much tries to play of six I guess
h3 f 6 g form and not easy g4 as a
threat anyway yeah that I couldn't
really answer dance questions properly
with this things with this that he
overlooks car moves this is something
that's tough to address it's really
tough to address and you have to usually
do it with some concrete game examples
so what happens here
f6 is still annoying and he tries to
play it tries to play it to get to my
default porn yeah it's not it's not so
easy to play and probably not good in
the first place yeah and probably have
to return that and exchange so if i take
now here i can go back i can go back
let's go five and see if I can open up
the position now and 5pm he still has a
huge pressure down
yeah i'm not sure what is going to play
probably and five okay yeah i'm giving
this back play rook t1 so i have a porn
down but I get activity here he almost
has to trade may be you plays rookie for
would be very sharp decision
you
catching up a little bit on the clock
yeah I mean okay if you does not take I
don't cut sure what is playing yeah this
one time morning so we can play rookie
to maybe I can take f3 now but I'm not
quite sure if i have to i also have h
for Bishop g5 as a plan check
I don't know I don't like to draw but
with the time situation I can add this
repeat once more maybe you would do
something else now usually it's too
tempting with the time advantage yeah so
he decided to continue to play my idea
is Bishop g5 opening or try to get the
excess to the aid it's got rooked you
five very well played ah shoot shoot
check check let's see if he can win this
doesn't seem to have a big plan here
available still handle the clock I don't
think I don't get that at all okay check
check check what a game blundering the
exchange in one year and and still gets
fantastic compensation those games are
always a bit unlucky Natalie Lowe 2400
oh it's a bad that's a bad bed run so
let's see I really there's a funny dis
discussion yeah and the Chad why certain
service ratings i inflated there is no
such thing this is a pretty much
pointless discussion there's no nothing
is inflated anywhere it's just what it
is there are different numbers of
players and ratings are different
because they only show and only do
shoulder the difference yeah like a 2400
is always higher than the 2300 but it's
absolutely not important how they
compare they are simply not comparable
in any way certain to service okay so
what about this
good development i can castle long next
okay I'll take now maybe cancels long
yeah sure on different servers different
ratings mean different things but this
is totally normal because they have
different players different player basis
and so on it's just there's no relation
whatsoever I mean if you play blitz on
the ICC not five minute but blitz
ratings on 3,500 I mean and this is this
is also um yeah it's just a just a
different different thing a different
different pool of ratings so what now be
night here I just want to play a little
bit quicker here I don't seem to not see
much anyway so I might as well play the
bad moves quickly
yeah there's a suggestion I should
rather keep it and play this is probably
an would probably be better for my
rating it seems that i'm not in good
shape which is kind of what i had
expected to be honest i really feel a
little bit a little bit under the
weather after the the weekend which was
busy okay so i'm going to take this and
my position is okay when it's nothing
great and i thought i should have a good
position but i don't have it it's okay
but nothing great at least this time i
was rather quick
yeah if people ask what is your rating
the only answer reliable one would be
some kind of feed rating national ready
not what you have on on on a chess
server okay let's stop age five yeah
play bad moves quickly as a good advice
our professional chess coach and
probably not but it's about it's about
blitz chess and play somewhat somewhat
okay moves quickly is usually a good
strategy and i hope i'm sticking with
someone okay moves
so can I win this pawn this is the
simple question that I'm going to ask
there's a Facebook chess rating you
learn new things every day I heard that
you can play chess somewhere with
facebook with with the chat or something
but I never I never explored that
possibility i don't use the messenger at
all i mean i use it if someone sends me
a message so I reply but I don't don't
use it that much in general so what can
we do here that will be tricky i guess
it will get the edge of this losing time
what did you do that check okay now i'm
getting the pawn running if it takes h5
no i don't see how IM ever gets back to
catch the pawn what how do you catch me
white reason he doesn't okay so I'm
pleased about 2,400 again and it was a
quick game I'm happy about that so let's
see if I can get a new one quickly game
start misko minutes co who is that me
long haha from Slovakia now maybe maybe
play this London system and this kind of
move water it actually has some points I
mean nothing brilliant but it has some
ideas this is one of them I don't know
that well but you can almost be sure
that the other side has no idea at all
let's go you can you can try this this
kind of thing it's a bit cheeky trying
to keep the pawn but maybe I managed to
do that it looks a little bit like a
notable variation but I have a bishop on
f4 which is the extra temple might might
be useful but might not be useful so i
can try to do this to have Bishop b5 if
you go screen GF 6 now this it it's true
if I don't play 1.e4 they will never be
a Smith [ __ ] so I will go with one you
form in the next game I think this is
this is a fair a fair deal there's a
question if I play crazy house no not
regularly I think it's quite an
interesting chess variant but I don't
play it regularly and sometimes if you
like okay let's play one or two games
but it's nothing I do on a regular basis
I
my hands full with regular chairs okay
yeah it could take and the question is
can I actually castle or not if I manage
to castle ya hear okay I have to do this
I guess 195 is also moving I do this I
also got a request for an English
opening yeah this is something that I
can definitely play c4 as kind of part
of my repertoire ok so here how do i
play here I think I'll take and then
castles I absolutely need to get the
hell out of the center here so this
looks good now in terms of pawns let's
March those pawns be five mi blundering
stuff I don't know be five rupee eight
possibly I don't have to play it
immediately I can I can do this and now
what to do I might double against that
pawn but ok this is probably this is
probably okay
no it's not trading okay um but I can
play b5 technically speaking take stakes
or technically speaking so I'll go I
don't play the Latvian no I really don't
do that anymore i mean i did that
sometimes for fun and I know that I
didn't lose all the games which is funny
in its by itself but it just absolutely
sucks to have a losing position
immediately and I don't know I just
don't want to be lost on move to
especially not if i'm not in the
fantastic shape to begin with um
basically i'm giving the other guy a
winning position from the get-go doesn't
feel like a good idea ok nitey 5 all
night to deform this is definitely help
for him so let's see what we can do
maybe just play simple move so here I
get a very nice square on d6
how many opening requests the nuns of
its laws on okay well that's here let's
see what kind of color have got more
game online but black ff4 this is at
least something of beta F form now he
played this against me recently and I
really hated that I didn't win that game
yeah from this opening i think it was
almost this position yeah i think that
black is already in good shape here so
27 the five gambit against the bird is
are things just incorrect and also not
necessary because you are better with
almost any line with black let's see i
try to get to d3 now maybe you can play
something Bishop t4 and Knight to c3
very strange position this is also
interesting
also quite interesting hmm what am I
doing here strange i have problems
against this player i usually just beat
him senseless lee my score was 11 like
10 out of 11 or so and then I lost the
game then i recently had on the channel
and here i'm also in in some trouble ok
this I actually think it's ok I should
have enough compensation for the porn I
think one key point in improving this is
playing regularly against a good or
decent opposition the reverse Grand Prix
and the English opening it's slightly
risky but it's playable I mean I
probably wouldn't like to play it
against super strong players but against
normal kind of persons it's ok
yeah I think I've got decent player the
opposite colored bishops I kind of noise
iam maybe I should have played it
differently you might get an e for now
in this position k Bishop c5 there is
you form when convince compensation
anyway but the question is what is best
can I do something really good something
really active Jim ok I'll go here yeah
this is isn't this just possible here I
think so for luke t two thoughts on
copying Oleg asus opening repertoire he
has a very good reopening repertoire
actually it's I mean it is sometimes it
is on the boring side not too
surprisingly but it is it is very well
thought out to get technical drive
positions and actually his opening
repertoire is a reason why I have my
problems in this in the games against
him because I have a hard time to get
positions that and where I can play on
my strength like a complicated middle
game something interesting with porn
structures and so on he just totally
drives down the position immediately and
I don't really have a recipe in the
opening against that yeah I kind of have
to play along with his dry positions at
least I don't see what to do against
there ok so here
much is happening let's see what we can
do oh wait I have to do something real
quickly let's see I think I'm running
out of running out of disk space here
which is not a good thing sorry I have
to get some new new disk space ready
here otherwise the this chamber well
well will guy down okay so it took a bit
of time yeah this a remark I could check
what strong GM's planning and stalling
us the thing is of course you can invest
time to prepare for an ICC blitz game
but I don't have it I just don't have
have this is this kind of time I I'm
actually I mean it's not that important
what you do against a certain player on
the internet what this guy is doing
actually is kind kind of strange she
could have just traded Queens earlier
and steady it tries to play this worst
position for no particular reason
yeah i mean it is still it is so dry of
course so any ideas at least sure not
much on Queen to g1 and then g 5 25 is
probably good Jeff it's almost
impossible here to do anything I mean
they're the opposite colored bishops
ending is a drawn so I don't want that
I'm a bit down on time
time morning I came this is probably not
really great but trying to still win
somehow no is there anything I can do
this one may be Queen have six then G
for now it's still a draw and I probably
should just make it okay it's really not
much I can do
this is just a draw check check
30-something seconds jang yesol I
kasparov played the Vienna gambit
against kawana I was surprised that Kara
wanna defended like you did because I
always thought that this is pretty okay
for white yeah I cannot do much quite
obviously yeah it is just a job let's
see game oh that's already five minutes
past eleven here okay be a time okay so
i would go with one day for a year right
i got a request for the Smith moral oh
that's not a Smith Maura ok yeah this
also how I know the story I think Alan
Rudolph didn't beat Oleg as it was um as
as hey buddy just said she betta one of
all he got his buddies so this is a very
boring position I didn't want to get
oops thank you okay winning lemon mousse
okie dokie was I know bishops III wasn't
known right
yeah I'm surely find a game it was kind
of a non-game yeah its beauty and I
wouldn't mind to have one but I got I'm
out of I'm out of the good stain started
ok con tourists yeah now it's playing so
what do we do I will go with some g6
baseline Kings Indian nope not 25 not if
five so early after Bishop g5 it's not
playable so have to be alert
yep I tried to go with f5 quickly but
would see what happens I wonder if F of
B 4 9 a-4 he might have not been fired
vs moon he has this one hmm i don't like
to go Knight b6 but I have to doesn't
look good I play against my own opening
line here I play the same variation he's
playing it like this is the easiest
thing ever and he has played it like a
million times is it really that easy
probably a son so what's the deal if I
cake yeah after I guess what happens
here
what the beep so if I can what if I
probably not my nights they suck
absolutely suck Queen f7 Queen f7 s
Bishop e3 so it doesn't look good I'm
wondering it looks a little bit like
that could be some tactics on d5 and so
on but I don't see a tactic I don't see
a tactic okay okay so it doesn't cover
have to probably it doesn't have to
maybe you can just take a seven it's
very much possible
um no he didn't do that he just wants to
check made me that looks very shaky for
me very very shaky
and don't tell me you're playing you
please for a draw now I can't believe it
what a chicken what a chicken and I have
to have to make the draw ah come on why
just has a fantastic position Airy makes
a draw yeah just like this or so and I'm
I mean what kind of stuff is that well I
probably should be happy with that with
that draw because I position is bad why
did he just draw maybe you just had to
leave or something like that you never
know okay um any questions I am Bishop
g5 at e3 against the Kings in Enda the
Swiss flow of control system that's a
good system it's very solid have play
today a couple of times and others
there's mention of her over the board
blitz cam video where we'll aghast
losses against 183 against grandmaster
Kramer and yeah this is kind of possible
because crema is also very regular on
that blitz player probably has suffered
against all I guess as well I played him
in the same event actually in the same
event and I played a troll ok I hope you
enjoyed the session I lost a couple of
points but i still i think it was decent
enough entertainment and i'll be back
next week next Monday same time same
place I hope you join me there as well
bye bye
you